I just want to check one last time that
you're okay about this date with mark oh
my god I'm so fine with it and seriously
it's so fine as long as you and I are
cool you know my code hos before Bros
uterus is before deuteron ovaries before
breweries hmm who makes your food coffee
I have stakeout supplies this is stuff
that would probably get me we have
notepads pencils and pencil case
shakable whipped cream cameras pork and
candy necklaces it's like we're real
police mmm
I hate salad I ate a brownie once at a
party in college it was intense it's
kind of indescribable actually I felt
like I was floating turns out there
wasn't any pot in the brownie it was
just an insanely good brownie feeling a
lot of confusing things right now yeah
no of course you are and your friendship
is the most important thing to me and
he's off-limits
I want to let you know I was really
serious about that special language no
hey hey so I was just at the grind and I
thought you might want an iced mocha
with extra extra whipped cream
oh my thank you so much April Wow you're
welcome oh by the way completely
unrelated I just signed up for the Miss
Pawnee beauty pageant that's wonderful
you know that is why I decided to become
a judge so that awesome girls like you
who are not you know classically hot can
be rewarded for their intelligence and
savvy it is impossible that he's not
gonna like you he's gonna freak out
about how awesome you are no I'm not yes
he is he's gonna love you you're cool
and you're sexy and you're funny and
you're smart
yeah any guy would be lucky to date you
Wow you are awesome and you are - thank
you you are - thank you you are - in
okay you're awesome you're awesome can I
get anyone anything to drink before we
start coffee brandy I'd love some coffee
hey guys some nuts awesome nuts gummi
bears
sure Apple crisps yeah granola bars I'll
take those nothing sure okay I'll be
right out there a TV I don't I don't
love the idea of corporate sponsorship
but sweetums is an institution when you
think of Pawnee think of sweetums got to
try this well hurt really bad Oh gray
camel stomach
I'm teasing up do you think it's chicken
would you like to try the camera stomach
no we just put a hundred degrees in
their body new trio by sweetums if you
can't beat oh sweet uh what's
galentine's day oh it's only the best
day of the year every February 13th my
lady friends and I leave her husband's
and her boyfriends at home and we just
come and kick it breakfast style ladies
celebrating ladies
it's like Lilith Fair minus the angst
Plus frittatas Oh ready to go yes your
keys please who's next
I feel great everything is running
smoothly Gleb bournemouth clipboard
mouth there's some secret ingredient in
these nutriyum bars it make me feel so
good sugar it's a block of sugar hey oh
hey sorry I can't hang out I kind of
have an emergency oh I'm actually here
to see mark right well thanks for the
coffee that's also for mark I really
mean it though but next time more sugar
okay thanks bye we just love if you
could come and join us
sure anything for my favorite customer I
bet you say that to all the girls oh no
no actually you're my favorite you've
been over a thousand dollars last year
on waffles alone oh hey there I got you
some waffles here courtesy of JJ's diner
and chicken soup courtesy of me I'll
take a waffle thank you so how did the
rest of the meeting go look cucumber
flower wow that's so cute wait that's a
garnish I'm supposed to eat that why
yellow haired female likes waffles and
news sexy well-read blond loves the
sweeter things and
much better Thank You Darla would
anybody ever eat anything besides
breakfast food people are idiots largely
you're a Pawnee girl no Leslie I'm not
well then why do you come here at
dinnertime and get takeout from the
legendary JJ's diner it's not for me
these waffles make great dog laxatives
don't you dare feed that waffle to that
dog to get it to poop
sambuca need to make there you go Leslie
this homemade bulgogi is so delicious
Kayla
this is the best Korean food I've ever
had I would say it's almost as good as
lukewarm beans from a can right Ron
although I have not worked with you
professionally as a private citizen I
have personally patronized each and
every one of your establishments and
I've never seen you buy a salad it's a
salad because I don't hate myself Tanya
I'm sorry I know I should be chasing
your vote but I stand behind my decision
to avoid salad and other disgusting
things and I think I have a lot of
support in the community for that you
okay it was a rough night but I survived
school they only have maple walnut in a
way my suspension from work was kind of
a blessing yeah I feel the same way
about resigning and disgrace totally the
key is you have to keep yourself busy or
else you're gonna go crazy I mean look
at me look how busy I am I'm inventing a
new spice called Saul ger it's a part
salt part sugar what could that possibly
be good on butterscotch pudding fair
enough
and put these scones in your bra let's
go okay can we just stop off at the LA
because the prison gift bags are amazing
I love me a calzone and going crazy
first thing will let me work at the
parks department now they won't let me
campaign either all I want to do is
improve our town and they won't let me
do that putting an awful lot of solder
on your pasta this is just sugar okay I
need you to distract me talk to me
something anything my heart was really
set on this new job yeah don't talk to
my pickles Aaron are you sure that you
don't need more whipped cream not today
I don't deserve it I got us into this
mess because I was fixating on that guy
but this is ridiculous I do need more
whipped cream ma'am I've only slept nine
hours over the past four days so I'm
right on the verge of a nervous
breakdown this isn't a bagel I'm in
favor of a lot of things like hot dogs
right Charlie I'm Leslie Knope and I
approve this message your tax on soda
would definitely lower diabetes in this
town oh I have a great prop for the
meeting this is the amount of sugar that
the average Pawnee ten-year-old consumes
from soda every month that is gross
gross all that sugar it's really gross
what a powerful image what are you doing
what did you put in the sugar it's so
good okay well I couldn't sleep a wink
last night so at 5:00 in the morning I
went to paunch burger for a pick-me-up I
couldn't decide what kind of soda I
wanted so I had them put all six in one
cup you know what it tastes like
disgusting mhm try it it's an
aphrodisiac you do my strange foreign
friend Leslie Knope soda tax forces
massive layoffs right now what's that
well since I can't give her a waffle
iron for breakfast day I am making her a
miniature Leslie out of breakfast food
[Applause]
this is the best breakfast day waffle
day join present I have ever received
Wow
is that Leslie no oh hi Gail what a
surprise I insist you join us for
breakfast this guy is the greatest
breakfast chef in the world not really
into breakfast foods
okay first is shaped like a waffle is it
are you sure you're cool with JJ's diner
catering what you've referred to as the
wedding of the millennium are you
kidding me I thought that I could not
love you any more than I already did but
was dead wrong scrambled eggs eaten with
chopsticks okay Andy and Leslie sent us
care packages hey Ben just a few things
to remind you of home love Leslie ah
waffle mix left that you can soup there
just in case it's a whole family recipe
it's not a big deal but thank you for
that okay
you